Antonyms.
Antonyms are words that have the opposite meaning as other words.
For example, the word "small" is the opposite of the word "big."
The word "hot" is the opposite of the word "cold."
A word can have more than one antonym!
Let's take a look at an example.
The word "hot" is the opposite of the word "cold,"...
...and the word "chilly" and the word "freezing"...
...so the word "hot" has more than one antonym.
See if you can find the antonyms in the following examples:
There was a loud noise coming from the other room.
Which word in this sentence is the antonym...
...or the opposite meaning of the word "quiet"?
If you said "loud," then you are correct.
"Loud" and "quiet" have opposite meanings therefore they're antonyms.
He came to school late today.
Which word in this sentence is the antonym...
...or the opposite meaning of the word "early"?
If you said "late," then you are correct.
"Late" and "early" have opposite meanings, therefore they're both antonyms.